[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر بركي
احييكم واقدم اليكم العربيه 300 حيث الخبر
من كل زواياه ومن جميع جوانبه
روسيا تتوعد اوكرانيا برد صارما على
استهداف موسكو بالطائرات المسيره
[موسيقى]
البرهان في احدث ظهور له يتوعد قوات الدعم
السريع بقوه مميته ما لم تتراجع
النيتو يدعو الى وقت فوري للتصعيد في
كوسوفو وينشر قوات اضافيه هناك
ولدينا ايضا
تحذيرات من فقدان الملايين وظائفهم بعد
خمس سنوات بسبب ذكاء الاصطناعي والروبوتات
نبدا من اخر التطورات تطورات الحرب في
اوكرانيا والتي نركز فيها على الهجوم
بطائره مسيره الذي استهدف موسكو صباح
اليوم لكن دعونا نتناول اولا اخر التطورات
في مقاطعه
فقد اعلن حاكم المقاطعه عن سقوط قتلى وجرح
جراء هجمات اوكرانيه استهدفت مناطق عده
سلطات قالت ان قصفا اوكرانيا جديدا طال
قريه نوفايا
بمنطقه
الاوكراني ذات المنطقه في قريه اخرى تدعى
مروم للمره الرابعه مع تحذيرات حكوميه
لسكان قريه كوزنكا بضواحي جرايفورون
بضروره الاختباء بسبب استمرار القصف من
قبل اوكرانيا
العربيه تعود مجددا لمدينه بيلجرد بعد نصف
عام تقريبا والمشهد هنا تغير بالكامل
هدوء مركز المدينه يشي بالترقب الحذر اذ
اصبح الوضع في باقي مناطق الاقليم
الجنوبيه والغربيه يعيش حاله حرب حقيقيه
وصفها خبراء بالاشد عنفا منذ اندلاعي
الحرب العالميه الثانيه
الوضع خطير للغايه مع غياب اجهزه الانذار
المتطوره التنبيه من الضربات ياتي بعد
حدوثها وهذا خطر خاصه ان المنازل متلاصقه
القصف لا يطال مركز مدينه الوضع مقلق بحيث
قد تطالون الضربات ونحن لا نعلم بها اتمنى
ان تهدى الامور في القريب العاجل
الملاصقتان للشريط الحدودي تنالاني حصه
الاسد من الضربات سلطات
لاجلاء قسم كبير من سكان تلك المناطق
وايوائهم في العمر الروسي
الوضع مقلق لكن ليس لحد الخوف الغالبيه
يدركون ان الحرب جاريه ويجب تحمل كل ما
ينتج عنها
القلق على سكان المناطق الحدوديه موجود
فالقذائف لا تميز احدا عن اخر وقد تصيب اي
شخص في الشارع لهذا الوضع بحاجه للتحمل
دون خوف
حصيله الضربات اليوميه على الاقليم خلال
الاسبوع الاخير تتنامى سريعا المنطقه
تتكبد الخسائر الاكبر جراء الصواريخ
وضربات المدفعيه حسب روايه السلطات بينما
تستمر المسيره برشق العبوات الناسفه على
البنيه التحتيه وتنال من شبكات الكهرباء
والاتصال والمياه والغاز والطرقات عبد
الجواد الروشد العربيه
يبقى معنا مراسل العربيه عبد الجواد الرشد
من بيلج اهلا بك كيف هو الوضع الان
مساء الخير الطاهر نعم يعني الوضع في مركز
المدينه كما تبعنا في التقرير هو مستقر
نوعا ما نسمع بين الفينه والاخرى عمل
انظمه الدفاع الجوي التي تقوم باصطياد
مسيرات قد تحمل عبوات ناسفه لكن طبعا طهر
على الشريط الحدودي في الكثير من المناطق
الوضع هو مشتعل بشكل كبير في اخر
التحديثات مقتل شخص واصابه قرابه عاشر
اشخاص في استهداف لمركز ايواء للاجئين تم
نقلهم طاهر خصيصا من المناطق الحدوديه
المشتعله هنا في بلغراد نحو العمق الروسي
هذا المركز يبعد قرابه 100 كيلومتر عن
الشريط الحدودي لكنه اصبح هدفا للمدفعيه
الاوكرانيه حسب روايه السلطات في المدينه
طبعا القلق يسود الشارع طاهر لا يمكن
اخفاء حقيقه جميع السكان يتحدثون عن ان
اقاربهم وذويهم واصدقائهم في المناطق
الحدوديه يعيشون وضعا صعبا عمليه اجلاء
كبيره من بعض المناطق قامت بها سلطات
المدينه طبعا للوضع المستقر نتابع في
الاخبار العاجله وخاصه على تيليجرام حيث
يقوم سكان تلك المناطق بنشر مقاطع الفيديو
والاخبار حول اما سقوط شيء ما او مسيره
ضربت احد المناطق او اصابات او تهدم لبعض
الابنيه في تلك المناطق
الخيارات العسكريه لدى روسيا لدينا هذه
الحرب عليهم اعتاد هذا الموضوع نعم اعذرني
على المقاطعه ما الخيارات العسكريه امام
روسيا الان
لكي تحمي هذه المناطق الحدوديه من اي
هجمات اوكرانيا مستقبليه
طاهر عمده راحه بعيدا قبل يومين وتحدث عن
ضروره السيطره على خاركيف في الاراضي
الاوكرانيه كي يضمن سلامه اقليم بيل جراد
لابد من التنبيه ان اقليم بلغراد طاهر
يتمتع بشريط حدود فاصل بين الاراضي
الروسيه والاوكرانيه يمتد لاكثر من 400
كيلو متر ولضبط هذا الموضوع يجب ابعاد
القوات الاوكرانيه حسب رايه قدر الامكان
عن مدينه خاركيف لذلك طبعا المناطق
المشتعله ان كانت وان كانت
جيفاروم هي مناطق طبعا تلعب الثالوث
بالنسبه لخاركيف يعني واحد على اليمين
وواحد على اليسار وتفصيلها بضعه كيلومترات
عنها وهذا طبعا يفسر حسب قراءه التحليل
العسكري في البلاد تعرض هذه المناطق لاكبر
موجه ضربات ان كانت صاروخيه او مدفعيه او
مسيرات او عبوات ناس شكرا جزيلا على كل
هذه الشروحات والمعلومات مراسل العربيه
استهداف العمق الروسي مجموعات معارضه
روسيه شنت هجمات مسلحه على بيل قرود خلال
الايام الماضيه كما تعرض الاقليم لقصف
بالصواريخ من اوكرانيا
وفي منتصف الاسبوع الماضي اعلنت البحريه
الروسيه عن صد هجوم بمسيرات على ميناء
سيباسبول في شبه جزيره القرم التي ضمتها
روسيا لكن هل كانت روسيا تستعد لهجوم على
موسكو الصور التي تم تداولها خلال الاشهر
الماضيه اظهرت نشر منظومات بانسير الدفاع
الجوي على مبانئ بالعاصمه ومنها مقر وزاره
الدفاع وحينها بررت السلطات الامر بانه
تدريب على صل هجمات جويه
وبشان الهجمات بالطائرات المسيره التي
استهدفت العاصمه الروسيه صباح اليوم اعتبر
رئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين ان الهجوم على
موسكو جاء ردا على ضربه روسيه على مقر
الاستخبارات العسكريه الاوكرانيه ويهدف
الى ترهيب السكان بوتين اشار الى ان انظمه
الدفاع الروسيه تصدت بكفاءه للهجوم
لم نطلق العنان لهذه الحرب في عام 2014
اختار نظام كيب معادله روسيا واضطهاد
الروس في دون باس ونحن لا نستخدم هذه
الوسائل التي يستخدمها قاده نظام كييف وما
حدث اليوم تاكيد اخر على ذلك المنشات
المدنيه السلميه في موسكو تعرضت للاستهداف
وعلى العكس من ممارسات الجيش الاوكراني
تنفذ قواتنا ضربات دقيقه ضد منشات البنيه
التحتيه العسكريه ومنها مقر المخابرات
العسكريه الاوكرانيه الذي تعرض للقصف قبل
يومين او ثلاثه ايام اختار نظام كييف
مسارا مختلفا مسار محاولات ترهيب روسيا
وتخويف المواطنين الروس وضرب المباني
السكنيه وهذه بالطبع علامه واضحه على نشاط
ارهابي
وزير الدفاع روسي سرقه بدوره اكد ان
القوات الروسيه تتكيف بسرعه مع التهديدات
وترفع من قدرات الطيران مضيفا ان دعم حلف
الناتو بالاسلحه لاوكرانيا سيؤدي لاطاله
الانشطه العسكريه
[موسيقى]
الدعم العسكري لاوكرانيا لا يؤدي الا
لاطاله الانشطه العسكريه الى ابعد من ذلك
ولكن لا يمكن ان يؤثر على نتيجه العمليه
العسكريه الخاصه وباستخدام اسلحه النيتو
يواصل منهم على راس السلطه في كييف شن
ضربات ضد المرافق الاجتماعيه وارتكاب
اعمال ارهابيه ضد المدنيين الروس وقواتنا
العسكريه حازمه في ردها على تصرفات
المسلحين الاوكرانيين
الخارجيات الروسيه من جانبها شددت على ان
موسكو تحتفظ بحق الرد واتخاذ الاجراءات
اللازمه للرد على هذه الهجمات ودانت
الوزاره في بيانها بشده العمليه مشيره الى
انها كانت موجهه ضد المدنيين وتهدف الى بث
الخوف والذعر بين المواطنين كما اكدت
الخارجيه ان استمرار الدعم الغربي لكياف
لن يؤدي الا الى دفعها نحو القيام باعمال
اجراميه متهوره
اذا ناموسكو شهدت هجمات متبادله بالطائرات
المسيره وادت لبعض الخسائر الماديه
والبشريه صباح اليوم استهدف ما لا يقل عن
30 مسيره العاصمه الروسيه موسكو وضربت
ثلاث مسيرات مبانيه سكنيه بينما اعلنت
السلطات اسقاط القسم الاكبر منها بحسب
وسائل الاعلام محليه في الروايه الرسميه
قالت وزاره الدفاع في بيان ان اوكرانيا
حاولت شن هجوم بطائرات دون طيار على منشات
في موسكو بمشاركه ثمان مسيرات تم تدميرها
جميعا هجوم اليوم ليس الاول الذي يستهدف
موسكو لكنه يعد الاقوى بعد هجوم الكرملين
في الثالث من الشهر الجاري اصابع الاتهام
الروسيه وكما هو متوقع اشاره لاوكرانيا
التي نفت الا ان مساعد الرئيس الاوكراني
توقع زياده مثل هذه الهجمات ومع استمرار
التحقيقات وعدم اعلان الطرف المهاجم
مسؤوليته بدا الحديث فرضيات الهجوم وان
كان داخليا ام خارجيا احد الاحتمالات ان
تكون المسيرات قد انطلقت من الاراضي
الاوكرانيه من اقرب نقطه على الحدود
الاوكرانيه الى موسكو ولكن المسافه تزيد
اعلى 500 كيلومتر ليطرحها هنا سؤال عما
اذا كانت اوكرانيا تمتلك مسيرات ذات مدى
طويل قادره على التخفي وتجنب الرادارات
والدفاعات الجويه الروسيه طول مسيره
المسيره من اوكرانيا الى موسكو الفرضيه
الثانيه المطروحه هي احتمال ان تكون
الهجمات تمت بتنفيذ خلايا نائمه داخل
روسيا نفذت سابقا عمليات في الداخل الروسي
نتحدث هنا مثلا عن الهجوم الذي اودى بحياه
المراسل الحربي المقرب من الكريم وهو
فلادين تتارسكي الذي قتل بانفجار بانفجار
تمثال مفخ اهدي له بمقهى فيتوسبورغ في
الثاني من ابريل الماضي الاتهام وجه
لمجموعات من المعارض المسجون
الاكسينافالني وبالتعاون مع الاستخبارات
الاوكرانيه لاحقا اتهمت مجموعات معارضه
داخل روسيا ايضا بمحاوله اغتيال السياسيه
والكاتب زخار بليبيين في انفجار عبوه
ناسفه على طريق كان يسلكها بسيارته في
السادس من هذا الشهر عده فرضيات تطرح اذا
ومجددا كما ذكرنا مع غياب تفاصيل اضافيه
سنحاول ان نستقرا المشهد كما يفهمه ضيفنا
على الاقل عسكريا معنا من موسكو المحلل
العسكري الروسي بافلجنهاور اهلا بك معنا
استاذ اذا هي خلايا نائمه في الداخل بسبب
استبعاد امكانيه ان تقطع مسيرات اوكرانيه
كل هذه المسافه مع التخفي عن الرادارات او
يمكن ان يحصل ذلك فعلا
هجمات السابقه
تمت
انطلقت من الداخل اما هجمات اليوم
فكان هناك مسيرات ذات اجنحه ثابته وهي
بحجم اكبر
ويصعب عليها ان تقوم
بان تؤدي مهامها داخل المناطق الروسيه لذا
من المحتمل
انها قد اطلقت من مناطق خاضعه للسيطره
الاوكرانيه وصولا الى موسكو هذا هو
الاحتمال المرجح
ليس من السهل ان يتم اكتشافي المسيرات من
قبل الرادارات للنظرا لصغر حجمها
لا تحتوي على بعض المواد التي يمكن
مشاهدتها من قبل الرادار ليس من السهوله
بمكان ان يتم اعتراض تلك المسيرات
رغم ما قيل عن انه قد تم اعتراض جلها
ولكنها احدثت ضررا فضلا عن الخوف النفسي
الذي ساد بين سكان موسكو
هذه التداعيات النفسيه قد تحمل نتائج غير
جيده في المستقبل ولكن نحن نتحدث هنا عن
500 كيلومتر هل يعقل حتى لو كان من الصعب
بمكان ان يعني
ترصد وان تستهدف ولكن نحن نتحدث عن 500
كيلومتر للرادارات ولا الدفاعات ولا اي
شيء من القوه العسكريه الروسيه قادره على
اعتراضها اذا يمكن ان نتخيل ان نوعا من
هذا المسيرات سيضرب دائما في العمق الروسي
وفي العاصمه الروسيه
هذه ليست طائرات بل هي عباره عن مسيرات
ذات اجنحه ثابته
ولا تحتوي على اي مواد شفافه يتم كشفها من
الصعوبه ان يتم اعتراضها والعثور عليها
الانظمه الدفاعيه في موسكو قد صممت منذ
العهد السوفيتي
لكشف ورصد الطائرات او لعلب
صواريخ الكروز لكن هذه اجسام صغيره وقد
تكون بحجم الطيور لدى فان النظام غير مهيا
وغير مصمم لمثل هذا الاعتراض لكن بصوره
اساسيه نعم قد جرى العمل على اعتراضها
ورغم ما تسببته من اضرار لكن الاثر النفسي
هو الذي كان خطرا ولكن يعني هذا ينذر
بالكثير من المخاطر على
وضع المدنيين في الداخل الروسي وهذا جزء
من قلقهم الان كما يعني راينا من خلال
استعراضنا لاراء الشارع الروسي اضافه الى
ما سنعرضه عليك قبل ان نعود لك سيد بابل
بشان الموقف الامريكي من الهجوم على موسكو
ولكن دعنا اولا نستقرا رؤيه الشارع
تراودني افكار للانتقال الى مكان اكثر
امانا هذا منطقي ومفترض حدوثه ماذا كانوا
يتوقعون
ما هو مقدر سيحدث لا يمكن الجلوس في
المنزل وعلينا التفكير في سلامه السكان
خاصه وان هذه العاصمه
لقد تجاوز نظام كييف جميع الحدود هو امر
محزن للغايه خاصه وانهم يوجهون تلك
المسيرات نحو المباني السكنيه والاشخاص
المسلمين لا توجد هنا مواقع عسكريه وبصرف
النظر عن اي شيء اود ان ارى جهدا لدينا
للعثور على الاشخاص الموجودين هنا لانه من
الواضح ان هذه المسيرات لم تاتي من
اوكرانيا
اما البيت الابيض فقد علق على الهجمات
بالطائرات المسيره التي استهدفت موسكو
وقال ان واشنطن لا تؤيد الهجوم على روسيا
كما اكد البيت الابيض انه لا يزال يجمع
المعلومات بشان هجوم الطائرات المسيره
الاخير على موسكو وشدد على انه يدعم
اوكرانيا لاستعاده اراضيها فقط
حرب الطائرات المسيره التي اتخذ استخدامها
ابعادا جديده في الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا تحمل اوجها عديده تكتيكيه ونفسيه
وماليه فلنتعرف واياكم الان على الاوجه
المختلفه لحرب الطائرات المسيره في
اوكرانيا
الطائره المسيره التركيه بيرقدار تي بي 2
كانت من ابرز ما استخدمته اوكرانيا في
بدايه الحرب استخدمت المسيره خلال العديد
من العمليات المسلحه المهمه كتعطيل
الاليات العسكريه الروسيه الاتيه من
بيلاروسيا او تدمير الطراد الروسي موسكو
على الجانب الاخر تمطر موسكو بانتظام
العمق الاوكراني بمسيارات متفجره من طراز
شاهد ايرانيه الصنع او ما تعرف بالمسيرات
الانتحاريه وبما انها اقل كلفه فهي تستخدم
من كلا الجانبين في محاوله لاستنفاذ
الدفاعات الجويه للطرف الاخر يتم استخدام
غالبيه المسيرات قرب الجبهه لاهداف
الاستطلاع او شن هجمات باستخدام طائرات
مسيره صغيره تجاريه يتم تعديلها لهذا
الغرض حدوث تحرك على جبهه معينه سيعطي
دورا اكبر للطائرات دون طيار التي
بمقدورها المشاركه في المعارك
نعود الى باب المحلل العسكري الروسيه من
موسكو امام مخاوف الناس في الشارع استاذ
باب المال خيارات التي تمتلكها موسكو
لحمايه مدنيها في الداخل
على زياده
قدراتي في الدفاع الجوي هذا قد يكون امر
محتمل لسنا متاكدين
مئه بالمئه اذا ما كانت هذه المسيرات سوف
تكون قادره على الاختراق لكن هذا الهجوم
يعد تصعيدا خطرا من نوى في الصراع
وفي ولكن الصراع بطبيعه حاله في اوج مراحل
التاجيل هو سوف متصل بالحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه وساعود اليك بعد قليل نستمع
الى مدير عام وكاله الطاقه الدوليه
للرفايل
اصحاب السعاده
سعاده المدير العام
ارحب سويسرا بالانخراط والالتزام
المستمرين للوكاله الدوليه لتقديريه
ومديرها لعام ضمانا لحمايه المنشات
النوويه المدنيه في اوكرانيا
لطالما ذكرت سويسرا هنا في المجلس بموقفها
تجاه العضوان العسكري
حيث تحدث فيها المدير العام للوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه رافاييل جروسسي
وقال انه الوضع بمحطه زفوريج النوويه
خطيره جدا داعيا روسيا واوكرانيا الى يعني
الالتزام بالمبادئ الضروريه
لضمان سلامه
هذه المحطه النوويه اذا وسنتابع مع
الاستاذ بابل الان وريثما يعني يرد اي
جديد من كلامه يقول لا يجب استخدام محطه
زفوريجا النوويه الان كمخزن للاسلحه
وتستظل يعني فيما يتعلق بما كنا نتحدث عنه
البيت الابيض يقول بانه هذه يعني هو لا
يدعم مثل هكذا هجوم على الداخل الروسي
الولايات المتحده بنفسها عاده ولكن الى اي
مدى باعتقادكم هناك جناح في داخل اوكرانيا
يريد الدفع باتجاه يعني توريط الغرب اكثر
ربما من خلال استهداف روسيا من الداخل الى
اي مدى هذا مغير في المعادله
راينا تصعيدا بصوره عامه في هذا الصراع
وسوف تكون هناك عمليه هجوميه وكنا قد
سمعنا قبل بضع ساعات من الرئيسكي بانه قد
اعطى الضوء الاخضر وتمت الموافقه على جدول
الهجوم وقد نرى تصعيدا على الارض وفي
السماء
وقد يتم العمل على شيء ما في المرحله هذا
هذا وهذا ما يذكرنا في
تمنيات القرن الماضي عندما اندلعت الحرب
بين ايران والعراق لعل شيئا ما يتم تحضيره
وقد نراه قريبا شكرا جزيلا لكم استاذ
المحلل العسكري الروسي من موسكو تحياتي
اليك
تشكل طائرات المسيره الانتحاريه المعروفه
باسم الكاميكازي خطرا كبيرا لقدراتها
التدميريه ويعد هذا النوع من الاسلحه
سلاحا فتاكا قد يغير من شكل الحروب
الحديثه
خلال الحرب العالميه الثانيه هجم طيارون
انتحاريون يابانيون سفن الحلفاء بطائراتهم
التي انفجرت بعدما اصابت اهدافها بدقه
فكان مصيرهم الموت
وبعد 80 عاما طائره الكاميكازي الانتحاريه
تعود للواجهه
ليله ساخنه في سماء موسكو وكيف تبادل
الطرفان فيها القصف عبر طائرات الانتحاريه
طائره الكاميكازي ولكن بلا طيار لها فعل
الصواريخ الباليسيه ولكن مع فرق فهي سهله
التصنيع رخيصه الثمن تطلق يدويا ضمنصات
بسيطه يمكن تغيير اهدافها بعد الاطلاق
يصعب كشفها تتمتع بقدره تدميريه كبيره
وتصيب اهدافها بدقه تمتلك الولايات
المتحده انواعا منها ابرزها الكاميكازي
اسرائيل طورت اسرابا منها تقطع 100
الكيلومترات وقدرتها التدميريه كبيره
تركيا باعت منها العشرات وايران قدمت
لروسيا طائرات شاهد التي لا تتجاوز قيمه
الواحده منها 20 الف دولار
الفصائل الفلسطينيه في غزه تمكنت ايضا
بامكانيه بسيطه من تصنيع اعداد من هذه
الطائرات كما برز مؤخرا استخدامها من قبل
عصابات اجراميه لتنفيذ عمليات قتل وتفجير
برمجه اهداف الطائرات الانتحاريه تتم
مسبقا عبر انظمه تحديد المواقع او التحكم
بها عن بعد بواسطه انظمه الاتصالات
والكاميرات المثبته عليها ما يجعل منها
سلاحا فتاكا سيغير من شكل الحروب الحديثه
[موسيقى]
فالعربيه 360 ايضا اليونيسف تحذر وضع
الاطفال في الخرطوم كارثيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد ومعلومات جديده من الجيش
الامريكي تصل في اخبار عاجله عن طائره
صينيه قامت بمناوره عدوانيه ضد نفاثه
امريكيه فوق بحر الصين الجنوبيه
والمعلومات تتحدث عن تحليق التيار الصيني
مباشره امام النفاثه الامريكيه وفقا لبيان
تابع للجيش الامريكي وذلك حصل فوق بحر
الصين الجنوبي في السادس والعشرين من هذا
الشهر من شهر مايو اي تفاصيل اضافيه فورا
ورودها الينا نتابع سودانيا الان قال
الجيش السودانيين الالتزام بالهدنه لا
يمنع من الرد على انتهاكات الدعم السريعه
قبل ذلك تعهد قائد الجيش السوداني عبد
الفتاح البرهان باستخدام القوه المميته
والمفرطه في حال لم تنصع قوات الدعم
السريعه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لكن اذا العدو منصاع وما استجاب حنضطر
نستخدم
اكد برنامج الغذاء العالمي سرقه 17 الف
طنا من المساعدات الغذائيه في السودان
معربا عن قلقه من ازدياد معدل الجوع الى
نحو مليونين ونصف مليون شخص خلال الاشهر
المقبله
لا تكفيهم القذائف المتساقطه فوق رؤوسهم
من كل حدب وصوب لا يكفيهم عدد الضحايا
الاخذ في الارتفاع لتسلب المساعدات
الانسانيه من امامهم وهي بالكاد تقيهم شر
الموت جوعا
اعمال نهب وسرقه متفشيه في السودان بحسب
برنامج الاغذيه العالمي التابع للامم
المتحده
فقدت بسببها كميات ضخمه من المساعده
الانسانيه
فقدنا حتى الان حوالي 17 الف طن من الطعام
في البلاد خاصه في دارفور منذ يومين فقط
كان مركزنا رئيسي في الابيض تحت التهديد
مكاتبنا الجاهزه واصولنا وبعض مركباتنا قد
نهبت بالفعل
التقارير تؤكد تفشي السرقه جراء الاقتتال
الدائر منذ سته اسابيع فيما يتقاضف طرفان
نزاع الاتهامات وتحميل المسؤوليه دون
الاكتراث بتوقعات بوقوع مئات الالاف من
السودانيين في براثن الجوع خلال الاشهر
المقبله
بصرف النظر عن 16 مليون شخص الذين سيجدون
صعوبه بالغه في تحمل تكلفه وجبه في اليوم
فان هذا الصراع سيزيد من السكان الذين
يعانون من انعدام الامن الغذائي بنحو
مليونين ونصف المليون شخص في الاشهر
القادمه
مشهد الجوع المتفشي في البلاد سيطال
اربعين بالمئه من السكان لاسيما الاطفال
لدينا الان اكثر من 13 مليونا ونصف
المليون طفل في السودان يحتاجون الى الدعم
المنقذ للحياه بشكل عاجل وهذا اكثر من
مجموع سكان السويد والبرتغال ورواندا
اوضاع ستزيد عمليات الفرار الى اماكن ودول
اكثر امانا لتشير التوقعات الامميه الى
نزوح اكثر من مليون سوداني بحلول اكتوبر
ورغم ان طرفي الاقتتال مدى الهدنه خمسه
ايام اضافيه لكن خروقات سجلت في الهدنه
السابقه وتسبب استخدام اسلحه ثقيله بدمار
كبير في البنيه التحتيه الزراعيه والمائيه
وتؤكد التوقعات انها ستطال مزيدا من
الارواح قتلا او جوعا في الايام المقبله
من القاهره ينضم الينا نادر نور الدين
الخبير الاستراتيجي لجمعيه العموميه
لمنظمه الفور اهلا بك معنا استاذ نادر هل
تستطيع الامم المتحده بهذه الحاله ان تحدد
المسؤوليات على من تقع في ضياع او سرقه
هذه المواد
والله المسئوليه ما زالت تائهه انه حتى
السفارات الاجنبيه السفاره الولايات
المتحده سفاره قطر تعرضت للاقتحام ايضا
اما كل برامج الاغاثه منذ بدء العمليات من
اكثر من خمسه اسابيع وايضا هوجمت ونهبت
تماما والان الشعب السوداني بالكامل يعاني
من انعدام الامد الغذائي لانه امكانيه
الوصول الى الغذاء منعدمه حاله الامن في
الشوارع منعدمه السيوله الماليه منعدمه
البنوك مغلقه منذ خمس اسابيع وبالتالي
الحاله صعبه للغايه كما جاء في التقرير
خاصه الاطفال 17.5 مليون طفل سوداني يعاني
يعانون تماما من امراض سوء التغذيه بعضهم
كان في المشافي يتعالج
وتوقف امداد الادويه اليه نسبه الاصابه
بامراض سوء التغذيه والتقزم مرتفعه في
الغايه في السودان على الاخص واليمن
وبالتالي الوضع سيء للغايه وانعدام ولكن
هل نحن على الاقل متاكدون من الارقام
الحقيقيه
لتلك المواد التي وصلت الى مستحقيها
بالفعل مقابل تلك التي سرقت
لا ما فيش ارقام صدرت لا من اليونيسيف ولا
برنامج الغذائي العالمي انما بيتكلموا انه
السودان في حاجه الى ما يقرب من مليار
دولار بشكل عاجل للاغاثه وتوفير جزء من
الامن الغذائي لانه حتى برامج الاغاثه لا
تستطيع التنقل بين المدن لتوصيل الغذاء
الى مستحقيه ولا حتى الى الاطفال ولا توجد
معسكرات لها من مستشفيات بعض القوات ايضا
اخذتها كاستطار ادمي في العمليات وبالتالي
انه الوضع يتدهور الى الاسوا وانعدام
الامن الغذائي قد قد يطال ال44 مليون
سوداني بالكامل اذا لم تنفذ الهدنه بدقه
ويسمحون بسلاسل امداد الغذاء بالتنقل ما
بين المدن السودانيه والولايات المختلفه
خاصه في دارفور في شرق النيل في الخرطوم
باجزائها هكذا سرقات في الامن مع حصول
هكذا سرقات عاده تتجه المنظمات الدوليه
الى وقف ارسالها ببساطه لانها ستعرض بعض
الطواقم للخطر ولن تصل المواد الى
مستحقيها وبالتالي سيستفيد منها ربما
امراء حرب فبالتالي هل تكون المناقشات
دائره على قدم وساق مع بعض الجهات لمحاوله
تامين طرق امنه لايصال هذه المساعدات او
ماذا
هذا ما حدث في الفعل في بدايه الاقتتال
توقف برنامج الغذاء العالمي لمده ثلاث
اسابيع واعلن اغلاق كافه مقره وانه اعلن
كمان قتل اربعه من العاملين في لتوصيل
الامدادات الامداد اثناء العمليات
وبالتالي دخلوا في مفاوضات مع الطرفين
حاليا بان السيارات التي تحمل العلامه
علامات الامم المتحده يسمحوا لها بالتنقل
ويسمحوا لها بالوصول الى ميناء بورت سودان
حيث تؤثر الامدادات من الخارج لايصالها
ولكن انه اذا كان الجيش السوداني موافق
ولكن قوات
الامداد السريع لم تعطي موقفا يعني واضحا
حتى الان وبالتالي ما زال ايصال الامن
الغذائي الى مستحقين ايضا معرض للنهب مره
اخرى
ولابد من اتفاق وتدخل اممي واذا كانت
المفاوضات الحاليه في جده برعايه المملكه
العربيه السعوديه والولايات المتحده لابد
ان تضع حدا لوصول الغذاء الى الاطفال والى
حاقين والفقراء نتيجه لتفشي الامن الغذائي
وكما قال التقرير انه اذا كان بيتوقعوا
اتنين ونص مليون سوداني يعانون من انعدام
الامن الغذائي تماما فالامر قد يمتد اكثر
من ذلك الى نصف الشعب السوداني على الاقل
واغلب كمان النوبات ونهب المواد الغذائيه
بتتم في دارفور البعيده عن الموانئ والتي
لا يصل اليها امبيرات الغذاء بسهوله
فالحقيقه برامج الاغاثه و برنامج الغذاء
العالمي بيبذل جهودا ضخمه لمحاوله انقاذ
الاطفال اولا النساء والحوامل ثانيا ثم
باقي الشعب السوداني نامل ان يكون صوت قد
وصل شكرا جزيلا لك نادر نور الدين الخبير
الاستراتيجي بالجمعيه العموميه لمنظمه
الفاو من القاهره تحياتي اليكم
[موسيقى]
العربيه 360 ايضا في البرازيل الرصاص
المطاطي وقنابل الغاز مقابل السهام
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اكد امين وعامل نتويان
ارسال قوه اضافيه من الحلف الى كوسوفو
وذلك عقب الاشتباكات التي وقعت هناك اضاف
النيتو انه اصدر توجيهات بنشر 700 فرد
سيكونون في حاله تاهب كما قال امين عام ان
الاعتداء على قوات الحلف امر غير مقبول
وان على السلطات الصربيه واتخاذ اجراءات
لوقف التصعيد وذلك بعدما حصل هناك
[موسيقى]
شمالي كسوفو حيث الازمات سمه المنطقه
تاريخيا تختلف اسباب التصعيد في كل مره
تحديدا في السنوات الاخيره لكن اساسها
يبقى برفض الصرب الذين يشكلون اغلبيه سكان
شمال كوسوفو اعلان الاقليم الاستقلال عن
صربيا الذي تم عام 2008 هذه المواجهات
مستمره منذ ثلاثه ايام بتجمع مئات من
الصرب امام حكوميه في بلده سفيكان
الحدوديه مع صربيا لمنع رؤساء بلديات
البان منتخبين حديثا من دخول مباني
البلديات لبدء مهامهم قوات من بعثه حفظ
السلام التابعه للناتو اشتركت مع شرطه
كوسوفو في التصدي للمحتجين ومحاوله حمايه
مبنى البلديه في وسط سبيكان
وخلال المواجهات العنيفه اصيب عشرات من
جنود بعثه حفظ السلام الدوليه
ادين بشده الهجمات التي تعرضت لها قوات
حفظ السلام في شمال كوسوفو والتي ادت الى
اصابه 30 منهم بجروح هذه الهجمات غير
مقبوله ويجب ان تتوقف رئيس وزراء كوسوفو
دافع عن الاجراءات التي اتخذتها حكومته في
بلديات شمالي كوسوفو
لا اوافق بشكل اساسي على مشروع القانون
بالسماح بقدر اكبر من الحكم الذاتي
للبلديات الذاتي الاغلبيه الصربيه في
كوسوفو
في الاثناء اعلن الرئيس الصربي ان 52
صربيا اصيبوا في الاشتباكات مجددا للتاكيد
على وضع قوته في حاله تاهب على الحدود مع
كسوفه تطورات المنطقه التي يخشاها الغرب
دفعت منطق السياسه الخارجيه للاتحاد
الاوروبي بمطالبه كسوف وصربيا بوقف
التصعيد الذي وصفه بغير المقبول من جانبها
دعت روسيا حليف صربيا التاريخي الى التوقف
عن القاء اللوم على السرب الذين يسعون
سلميا للدفاع عن حقوقهم او وفق قولها
مطالبه بخطوات في وقف التصعيد حنان المصري
العربيه
[موسيقى]
ارسلت الصين اليوم ولاول مره رائد فضاء
مدنيا باتجاه محطه تيان جونغا الفضائيه
الخاصه بها وانطلق اليوم للمحطه ثلاثه
رواد فضاء بهدف تعزيز خبره الصين في
الرحلات الماهوله ومحاوله اللحاق
بالولايات المتحده وروسيا في هذا المجال
المهمه تشكل تجربه كبيره للصين التي تسعى
لارسال رائد فضاء للقمر بحلول عام 2030
وهو من الاهداف الرئيسه في البرنامج
الفضائي الصيني
في هذا العرض نتعرف على الفوارق بين محطتي
الفضاء الدوليه والمحطه الصينيه محطه
التيان جونج الفضائيه الصينيه او القصر
السماوي بلغه المندرين الصينيه تتميز بحجم
اصغر من نظيرتها الدوليه ويكون حجمها
يقارب خمس حجمها يقارب خمس حجم المحطه
الدوليه وبينما تاسست محطه الفضاء الدوليه
بين عامي
1998 و 2011 كانت اول عمليه اطلاق لتركيب
المحطه الصينيه عام 2021 اما عن المدار
الذي تدور فيه المحطات فيتراوح بين 420
و450 كيلو مترا عن الارض اهميه محطه
الفضاء الصينيه تاتي من حداثتها وايضا
لانه من المتوقع ان تبقى في الفضاء ما لا
يقل عن عشر سنوات قابله للتمديد بينما
ستخرج محطه الفضاء الدوليه من الخدمه في
موعد اقصاه
وثلاثون الصين ذكرت انها لا تعتزم تكريس
محطتها الفضائيه لاغراض التعاون الدولي
مثل محطه الفضاء الدوليه لكنها رحبت
بالتعاون الاجنبي دون تحديد نوعه هنا يطرح
التساؤل لماذا ليست الصين جزءا من محطه
الفضاء الدوليه اصلا الامر يعود الى حظرها
من المشاركه في المحطه وفقا لقانون وولف
الذي اقره الكونجرس الامريكي عام 2011
ويحضر اي تعاون امريكي صيني في برنامج
الفضاء لمخاوف من سرقه التقنيه او اخطار
على الامن القومي ويرى خبراء ان الحضره
الامريكي اسهم في تسريع خطوات البرنامج
الصيني الذي يعمل على تشكيل المشهد
المتغير للقوه المتنافسه في الفضاء بهذا
يمتد التنافس بين الصين والغرب في كل
المجالات وصولا لغزو الفضاء
خاصه وان بكين تخطط لاطلاق تلسكوب فضاء
بحلول ديسمبر المقبل معنى من بكينا تشاو
تشي جيونا صحفيه متخصص في الشؤون السياسيه
الدوليه اهلا بك معنا استاذ تشاو جيون في
العربيه
360 وما طبيعه التعاون التي يمكن للصين ان
تقبل به دوليا في هذا الاطار في محطتها
خاصه مقابل التعاون الدولي الاخر الناتج
عن محطه الفضاء الدوليه
اهلا ومرحبا بكم طبعا الى هذه المحطه
الصينيه
مهمه لسين
العرب كلهم وتم اطلاعكم المركبات الفضائيه
16 على متن صاروخ الحامل يوم الاثنين
لاتلاك
الصناعيه وحيث داخل ثلاث رواد الفضاء الى
الفضاء بثلاثه
ليحولوا محل حاكم الموجوده في المحطه
المدنيه
لمده سته اشهر وحققت محمد الماخوله الاولى
في مرحله
التدبيك وتدوين لبرنامج محطه فضائي
الصينيه النجاحا كاملا ويعني من خلال هذه
المحطه يمكن
للواد الفضائي والرواد
فلا يمين مختلفه لبلدان
لاجراء البحث علمي تجاه الفضاء
اكثر من
اكمال الصناعيه
لتحسين معيشه شعب لمجتمع دولي ويدوم
رواد الفضاء جديد مدنيا لاول مره وبعد عن
مكان جميع افراد اتاك سابقين من من جيش
تحاليل شعبيه صينيين لاول مره يكون مدنيا
لماذا ما يعني
الرسائل التي تبعث من وراء ذلك واي جديد
يمكن ان يطرا على كل هذه الصناعه
بطبع مثلا في
مجال الزراعه
وموارد
واستقلاك على موارد طبيعيه من خلال هذه
المحاطه الفضائيه الجديد
واعمال الصناعيه الجديد يمكن عن يمكن
للبشريه عن عن يلاحظ الحاله الاساسيه عن
عن عن
مثلا
كيفيه تعزيز زراعه
كيفيه
تعمل على موارد طبيعيه في العرب فيمكن من
خلال هذه
الاقمار الصناعيه جديد والفضائل
الفضائيه الصينيه ويمكن ليس فقط
لسينما دولي يمكن ولكن الى اي مدى تعتقد
بانه الصين حققت حتى الان يعني منجزا
كافيا يمكن ان تنافس به او ان تسبق به
الولايات المتحده والدول الاخرى في خلال
سنوات قريبا هل بكين على هذا المسار فعلا
نعم طبعا هناك
تتنافس الصين والولايات المتحده ودول
القلبيه في في مجال الفضائي
ولكن قد ليس ليس هنا شك في عن الولايات
المتحده تقود طريقه حاليا في المجال في
الفضاء ولكن مثلا اكدت مدير وكاله ناسا عن
السباق الفضائي الحاليه لا يقتصر على
الولايات المتحده وروسيا بل يشمل ايضا
المنافسات بين
انه يتعين على الناس واداره فضائل الصينيه
عدم تنفيذ تعاون معامج ولكن اعتقد
من جانب من جانب باكين قد اعرضت عن
البحث عن
[موسيقى]
من الفضاء الى اخبار الذكاء الاصطناعيه
حيث حذر خبراء من ان الملايين من العاملين
في مجال الوجبات السريعه سيفقدون وظائفهم
في فتره تتراوح بين خمس الى عشر سنوات
وذلك بعد ان تحل محلهم الروبوتات وانظمه
الذكاء الاصطناعي
[موسيقى]
موظف قطاع مطاعم الوجبات السريعه في مرمى
الذكاء الاصطناعي والمهله امامهم ما بين
الخمس والعشر سنوات بعدها قد ينتهي الوجود
البشري في هذا المجال وتحل محله روبوتات
وانظمه اتمته كامله بدءا من اخذ الطلبات
مرورا باعداد الطعام وانتهاء بتقديمه تطور
يوصف بالثوري فللمره الاولى سينتقل الذكاء
الاصطناعي ليشغل وظائف يتعامل فيها بشكل
مباشر مع البشر مؤسس شركه فاليانتا
المتخصصه في الذكاء الاصطناعي روبكار قال
اننا سنرى الذكاء الاصطناعي يقفز من
المكاتب الخلفيه الى الوظائف في الواجهات
الاماميه والتي كانت حكرا على البشر
كاربين ضرب مثلا بتقنيه الذكاء الاصطناعي
المعروفه باسم هولي والتي اثبتت قدرات على
عمليه البيع تفوق قدرات البشر كما اعتبر
كاربنتر ان محركه لا يمتلك القدره في
التفوق على البشر في حال استلامه اكثر من
الطلب التحذيرات من ان يحل الذكاء
الاصطناعي محل البشر ليست الاولى اذ نشرت
مؤسسه جولدمان ساكس في مارس الماضي تقريرا
يوضح ان الذكاء الاصطناعي يمكن ان يستحوذ
على نحو ثلاثمائه مليون وظيفه من البشر
وبدوان كامل وهو ما قد يجعل البشر امام
مستقبل غامض مع منافسهما الذكي ولو
اصطناعيا سوره اليوم في العربيه 360 من
افغانستان تبقى قليل من الوقت لكن ما زال
بامكاننا اللعب قبل ان نكبر وحينها ستتغير
حياتنا فلا دراسه ولا عمل الصوره التقطت
في مدينه جلال شرق افغانستان
فيديو اليوم من البرازيل حافظوا على
حافظوا على عاداتهم وملابسهم التقليديه
وحتى اسلحتهم البدائيه لمئات السنين اما
اليوم فهم يستخدمونها خلال مواجهات مع
الشرطه انها ساو باولو كبرى مدن البرازيل
اما هؤلاء فهم سكانها الاصليون خرجوا في
تظاهرات احتجاجا على مشروع قانون من شانه
حرمانهم من اراضيهم الاحتجاجات سرعان ما
تحولت لمواجهات مع الشرطه التي استخدمت
قنابل الغاز والرصاص المطاطي اما هم
فاطلقوا السهام للرد على الشرطه
شكرا لمتابعتكم العربيه 360 لكن اخبار
الساعه لا تنقطع وميسون الوجه تتابع فيها
الان ميسون مساء الخير ماذا لديك مساء
الخير طاهر طبعا اول المواضيع اليوم هي
حرب المسيارات بين اكياس روسيا ايضا لدينا
التخوف من قبل الاتحاد الاوروبي لما يجري
بين كوسوفو وصربيا ايضا تطورات في السودان
وتصريحات السيد البرهان بالاضافه عن انباء
تتحدث عن موعد جديد للانتخابات في ليبيا
والعديد من الاخبار نامل ان تتابعنا معك
تفضلي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات